imagine this is futuristic but it's not
beyond science
that you you have this virus now and if
you break
a bone or you break your back or rip
your eye
you get an iv of this antibiotic and uh
you rejuvenate like a salamander
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
i have to say that i was a little
intimidated
by today's guest david sinclair he
is a professor at harvard has over 35
patents he owns labs we had
a fascinating conversation i of course
did my research like i don't know to ask
about
cellular programming anybody that's been
listening to this podcast knows that i
just truly love learning
and i i just really love having
scientists and doctors and experts
on the show because it's part of that
process i think that we
we grow through of course that
self-reflection and our own work but we
also grow through just
learning more and and just having that
education of how to treat ourselves
better and how to take care of ourselves
better
mind and body so today we're going to
learn about how to take care of the body
and we're going to also learn about
you know the future of how we can repair
ourself
david is a scientist but he specializes
in the field of anti-aging
what his main focus is that quality of
life it's not about living forever it's
about
being able to live more fully and
while you are here and so we talked
about the science we talked about how to
do it we talked about
the best kind of diet the best kind of
exercise
and uh basically i have to go back to
this episode and listen so i can write
down all the things that he said because
it was a lot to soak in in the moment
but there's a lot of amazing information
in this episode so take it all in and if
you have to re-listen
re-listen well so we can't fix yet the
that presbyopia but we can have a
dead retina come back to life so if
you've got macular degeneration or
glaucoma or just old age
then you get your vision back if you're
a mouse but hopefully we'll do it in
humans but it's proof of concept we can
talk more about it
yeah proof of concept that we can turn
back the age of a tissue
is it genetic genetic treatment okay
but when we're not turning back not
changing the genes
we're telling the cell how to read the
genes like
a young cell does and we think aging is
caused by
um if the genome were a piano
the piano player becomes demented and
we're
bringing in a new piano player to play
the piano
and basically it works and you get back
youth you get out back eyesight
so that's what's in the book um
towards the end and i'm spending most of
my time now trying to make this into a
drug
that and 14 others that's because you're
a brilliant scientist
and i so i wasn't even going to
i mean when i'm reading all of your
accomplishments your bio what you've
done
all of the projects you're involved with
and companies
i mean i struggled to pronounce all the
words
in it all and i'm just going to say
you're extremely accomplished
and how are you so driven to it then i
thought you know that's not fair
and i need to try a little harder and
make sure that people
you know i just think that that that
understanding for your
your knowledge and your acknowledgments
for what you've done is such a nice way
to set the stage before we talk
about all of these things so look i i
wrote down i'm not arrogant you can do
whatever
high points of high points is what i'm
calling them
uh so you have a phd in molecular
genetics
you're an inventor of over 35 patents
a professor at harvard we have the
sinclair lab
co-founder of at least seven labs and on
the boards of many others
co-founder of the journal aging
your work has been featured in five
books two documentaries on 60 minutes
and then morgan freeman's through the
wormhole
you have over 25 awards and honors for
your accomplishments
and time magazine named you
one of the 100 most influential people
time's up we already know time's never
up for you because you are an expert in
not aging
uh right you're very kind um there are
there are some bad things you could say
about me but let we can stick to the
good why would i do that
you're my honor i'm honored to have you
as a guest and i
thoroughly enjoy learning and while the
show has
a lot of um there are a lot of episodes
that i do with people and we
dive into your personal life a little
bit as far as
what struggles you've had and the growth
that you had from it and i
would love to talk about those things
too because it's it's part of the human
element
of learning and growing and relating and
and being inspired to do it yourself
but i also love to have episodes where
we're all able to be educated and can
open our mind up to new possibilities
obviously in this
scenario specifically to science and
the science of not aging which is a huge
business
gigantic business um so
where uh tell me about you know some of
the fundamentals of your upbringing
and where you came from and then just
how
you have been able to be so driven so
focused and
and um obviously excel so much in the
field of science and
and of course then there's aging but
it's just science in general i mean
you're well accomplished
uh well thanks for having me on yeah
first of all um
you're just as accomplished
but uh so i'm i have a ged let's just
keep that
really make sure everybody knows that um
you
have a phd uh yeah but i haven't won
many
uh race uh car events but um
i have been known to drive too fast okay
good i like it uh
not good i've actually i lost my
driver's license in two continents
how how are just not behaving well i
drive
safe now but as a youngster um
i had a need for what countries were you
in
i lost first lost my license in
australia
uh and then and then in the us uh
you have it back now yeah i've been very
good for the last 20 years
but i was a bit of a speed demon and
drove
uh okay so how did your parents feel
about that
um i don't know what were your parents
like um so my parents
are uh very
uh caring they're if if anyone's
responsible for me
being rebellious it is partly my parents
who let me do it whatever i wanted
and they would they would never get
really angry they would just
they'd get upset but um so i was allowed
to just play
i was naturally curious i would go into
the backyard and i grew up on the edge
of the australian bush
and i had literally a million acres in
my backyard
wow i could work for walk for weeks um
and for that
that was my laboratory i would pull
apart dead animals and
spiders and trying to figure out how
things work that's what i
like to do um and i still do that it's
just
now i get paid to do that which is a
great anyone who wants to be a scientist
that's what's great about it you get to
do what you did as a kid but get paid
and then teach other kids
and so i was very curious and i
explored a lot i've always wanted to
know where do things come from
and there was a river in my backyard and
i would follow it trying to find the
source
of the river and i never did get all the
way to the beginning of the river it was
a long way probably 50 miles away
um similar to ponce de leon never found
the actual fountain of youth and i'm
still looking for something like that
it's a good metaphor for my childhood
yeah and i'm a parent now so i
i'm not a good parent um i try to be but
it's it's very hard to let your kids
really explore and do dangerous things
because you worry too much but i was
allowed to do things that
i would never let my kids do just wander
off and be gone for
half a day i think that's the story of a
lot of people though there is
a lot more fear-based information out
there
[Music]
perhaps bad things were going on but you
just didn't hear about it all the time
it wasn't on the news it wasn't on
social media
and so you weren't thinking about it
and it wasn't part of your reality then
that you thought
oh um david's gonna go out and he'll
come back when the sun goes down and
whatever he does i'm sure he'll be fine
you know like now we're thinking and
what could be and there might be
somebody out there and what if and then
oh my gosh
and that's just that's just the nature
of life has become more fear-based in my
opinion so
you know we used to be able to ride our
bike anywhere and now we'd be like um
yeah the driveway is uh probably the
only safe place
um we're gonna keep those training
wheels on where do you
where do you get the drive to see
things through that are so
well that have never been proven and
that are so new
well you look at history there's plenty
of pioneers who
just want to do something for the first
time ever
and that's what drives us we want to
accomplish something that we can feel
proud of and
leave the world different and better
than we found it
and that's what really is fundamentally
my fear is that
i don't want to be inconsequential i
want to
die knowing that my life was spent doing
something
useful and i think that's the basis of
it all
and i was looking for something
consequential to do with my life
i was a very depressed
person in my early 20s and i've never
told anybody that
and the reason was that i was fearful
that i wasn't
going to live up to my expectations for
myself
because i was in i was in australia in
sydney and scientific scientists in
sydney don't typically get jobs
and i thought i'd have to become a
lawyer and there's nothing wrong with
lawyers but my personality doesn't
suit it as soon as i got into a lab
and started tinkering pulling things
apart putting back together then i fell
in love with
with molecular biology so i immediately
got a phd in that
but the big question that i wanted to
solve which i still think is the biggest
problem
facing humanity is
why do people get sick okay
and the traditional way of approaching
that is we're going to find a cure for
that once it happens or cure for cancer
cure for heart disease which is great
and i'll be the first to
recommend that because my mother passed
away from lung cancer
but if we were to stop cancer today in
everybody across the planet
the average lifespan wouldn't go up by
more than two and a half
maybe two and a half years really yeah
it's surprising isn't it
the problem is the major cause of death
and illness is aging
it's what causes heart disease and
alzheimer's you don't kids don't get
typically alzheimer's why is that
we forget why we we're focused on what
causes people to fall off a cliff
and we're trying to stop them at the end
from falling off but we forget what
drove them
to the cliff in the first place what
have you learned wanted to
figure out what drives us to the cliff
why do we age
what has been why don't we stay young
what was your first aha
moment with that with figuring that out
yeah well so i came to the us in 1995
to figure it out using simple organisms
yeast cells we use for beer and bread
and i i thought if we can't figure it
out for a microscopic yeast cell
we'll never figure it out for humans so
let's start simple and i'm i was trained
in genetics
fortunately in yeast genetics and the
first
aha moment was that we could
uh i had to guess why the yeast were
getting old
i had this aha moment middle of the
night 2 a.m
woke up and suddenly all of the
observations over the last
year and 10 years before me put it into
a hypothesis wrote it down
in a book which i still have in my
office uh it was a
uh october 26th name of the book uh it's
just my live book your book okay
yeah okay you wrote it into your lab
book it's in the book but but there's
actually excerpts
where i wrote a theory on aging i
cut that out and put it into my my
current oh is this the digital versus
analog the theory of aging yeah
please explain okay i don't we'll get
there but anyway continue on with your
aha moment so the aha moment was that i
think we could figure out why
an organism gets old it was a yeast cell
but
actually all i've been doing for the
last 25 years is taking that idea
and testing if it's true for us and so
far
it looks like it is very relevant
well how do you do it oh how do you do
it yeah i mean that's the key that's the
magic sauce
okay so what what do i think causes
aging well let me give you a very brief
uh catch up on history
in the 1950s we really had a big effort
in figuring out why we age and it was
the nuclear era and everyone was worried
about dna damage and mutation so
the theory was we damaged the the genome
the dna
and that's why we age and you still hear
that's probably what most people think
causes aging
uh many of us myself included thinks
that's not right that's not the main
cause number of reasons why uh you can
clone
people you can clone animals for sure
right but i'm pretty sure i could take
your cells and clone you animal or
person
have you seen a cloned animal not with
my own eyes have you seen a cloned
person
uh no of course not they don't that's a
liar
but barbara streisand would tell you
that her
dogs are clones and she paid a lot of
money for them so
hopefully they're real but they're
identical to her previous one
anyway so cloning hey it's okay
that's okay i have to ask i'm very
curious no it's a good question
but i i trust that the scientific
journals that publish cloned animals
and show that they're healthy are real
but i would like i would like to see a
cloned animal that's for sure but what
that tells us is
the genetic material in an old animal
and where we're animals uh is still
intact
so let's let's take it that the
digital information uh the dna is intact
in our bodies
so why do we age if the information is
still there right there's another type
of information in the body
which is not genetic it's called
epigenetic
and that is just a fancy word for
the structures that read the dna
right we've got to read the dna because
every cell has the same dna
but not every cell is a nerve cell some
are liver cells some are skin cells
and the difference is that it's a
different pattern of which genes are on
and off
and that's what makes us healthy babies
it starts with one cell
you get 26 billion cells each one with a
different pattern
of what we call gene expression can you
so can you change
your epigenetics can epigenetics be
changed or is that or is it a gene
expression
is the can you change the expression is
that the same thing as epigenetics
yeah okay yeah uh you can do it right
now
do you want to do it yeah okay hold your
breath
all right you just did it yay
it's easy right so 80 of our longevity
is non-genetic it's how we live our life
and having lack of oxygen so
running having a lack of food fasting
um being probably being cold and hot and
shocking your body is also a way
to make your body fight against the
ravages of aging
and it's all about preserving that
epigenetic
information so i can explain how that
works
please so we didn't really know 50 years
ago what the epigenome was we just knew
that it was there
and we know that it has to be there
because you make a baby and a baby is
from one cell but what the epigenetics
people the scientists who study
development of a baby
they didn't think into the future they
didn't care about aging that's something
someone else's problem
but i think that aging is merely
unraveling of what
happened up till birth so cells use
their epigenome to play the right
music on a piano to make perfect bodies
essentially perfect if you're lucky but
what happens during aging i think is
that the cells
lose their ability to play those genes
in the right way
the gene expression gets messed up we
call it epigenetic noise
and cells 80 years later have forgotten
their original identity and that's aging
that causes
disease that causes heart disease and
frailty and alzheimer's
i believe so how do you forget how to
play
your genetics well so the genes are
controlled by bundling them up so dna is
a string
six feet in every cell and it's not just
flailing around like a piece of string
it's actually bundled up
either into big loops that are open up
opened up so the cell can read those
genes
and you get groups in these loops groups
of genes and then genes that shouldn't
be on let's say if you're a nerve cell
you don't want the liver on
so you bundle those up tightly like you
would take a hose and
spill it up on your driveway and those
are the tight bundles so you've got
bundles and loops bundles and loops
and that gets messed up and one of the
ways it gets messed up we've shown
is that if you cut or break a chromosome
that's a disaster for the cell if you
break a chromosome basically you're
going to
die as a cell or you're going to become
a tumor
this is really bad so what the cell has
to do is unpack
those loops and those bundles to help
repair the dna
stick it together we have these glue in
the cell and then they have to package
it all back the way it was
originally and there are proteins that
do all this and they have to move from
here to here to here to here
and some of them we think get lost in
the same way
these repair proteins are like the army
core of engineer that goes to help
hurricane katrina victims they don't
always come back to where they were
and over time this movement called that
ping pong match
eventually lose those beautiful
structures of loops and bundles
and that we can do in a mouse and those
mice
look old they get diseases of aging they
get the hallmarks of aging which
are things like loss of energy loss of
stem cells
all that good stuff but as i wrote
kind of in a teasing way in my book if
you can give something
like aging to an animal you can take it
away
and so we've been working on
understanding not just what drives aging
forward
but now that we have a better idea of
what's doing that can you slow it
yes we can and can you reverse it and
that's where we are right now is working
on
is there a backup copy of the music
of youth in the cell and where is that
and how do you tap
into it you said it you talked about
breaking a chromosome
yeah how do you break a chromosome well
it happens in our bodies naturally all
the time
um a few times in every cell so that's
trillions of times per day
but we can accelerate that in the lab we
engineer mice
to have an enzyme that that cuts the dna
precisely in
a few places we can turn that on with a
drug
just a chemical we put in their water or
food and then it cuts their dna for a
few weeks when they're young
it all gets put back together nicely so
there's no mutations the dna
information is still there but then we
wait
and over the next few months they start
to get old more rapidly and they get
gray and hunched and they lose their
vision and they get
demented so we're constantly breaking
chromosomes and repairing them
yeah so there's an issue with the repair
and that
that transporting back and forth of
these repair proteins repair proteins
that get
lost and then were unable to then
read the program read the genetics
epigenetics is not able to read the
music
yeah the g the the your genetics well
enough to
continue with the same performance
essentially as
you originally had and then you get old
exactly exactly and what's important
about that is
it means that the information to be
young is still in your body even when
you get old
we didn't know that until recently so
what is nda then nad sorry nad
nad is because i can't say the words so
i'm gonna
ask if you'll say what nad stands for
and then tell me what nad
is so nad it stands for nicotinamide
which is a form of vitamin b3 adenine
dinucleotide yeah now everyone knows why
i can't concentrate yeah
yeah it's basically vitamin b3 attached
to a sugar attached to phosphorus
that's so much that's much better it's
still difficult but much better but it's
a tiny little chemical and it's
one of the most boring chemicals um in
biochemistry
but isn't it important it is we did we
didn't know until the
2000s that it was it was linked to
longevity
we thought it was a housekeeping
molecule i mean don't get me wrong it's
important if we didn't have nad we'd be
dead
no right in seconds um it's
required for most chemical reactions and
the energy it's the same's life but
that's still boring
stuff it was all figured out in the
1960s
but when we came along in the 2000s
we discovered that there are sets of
enzymes that protect the body
against disease and aging they call the
sertuans
and they need nad to work and
they don't just need a little bit of nad
they need a lot of it
and when you're sick and when you get
older you have less and less of this
nad molecule you don't make as much and
you actually chew it up we think
and uh so what happens is the sirtuins
which are
keeping all the packaging correct and
making sure cells don't get sick
as they get older they lose their
activity
so without the nad they don't protect
the body
now when you there are some ways to
boost up nad i'm sure you want to
hear about that of course well one is um
stay young uh but uh that we're still
figuring out how to do
but the other things you can do you'd be
surprised to
to learn that exercise or you may not be
surprised
is exercise and you it is but did anyone
know why
straining the body you're talking about
all kinds of things like dragon ball
exercise you're talking about hot and
cold you're talking about
starvation so you're you're talking
about extremes so
mitochondria adaption something like
that i mean i'm really
a little um embarrassed about saying
these big words but i'm not sure what
i'm talking about but
you're absolutely right um so what i
have a
saying in my lab is we can always give
an explanation
but we have to ask the question why
five times and so you've just said
something that's true which is
uh sortunes and and diet all of these
good things
uh protect the body okay but then
you gotta ask yeah well how does that
happen and so what
i'm proposing is that the nad levels are
activating
the sirtuins and
stabilizing the the information in the
body and repairing
cells and that's the reason why exercise
and diet
is good for you it's not the blood flows
around it's not that
just that mitochondria are boosted it's
that we have these
innate defenses in our body that become
complacent
if we sit around if we eat too much food
if we don't exercise
because they evolved to keep us healthy
when times were tough
problem is in our world today times are
never tough unless you make them tough
so you're right what doesn't kill you
makes you stronger
but what's exciting about the science of
aging is now we understand why
there are these genes that we have yeast
cells have them
we have them bananas have them whales
have them and they
serve to protect us but we've been
trying so hard to get rid of any
adversity in our lives they don't bother
working
anymore so how do we you're saying nad
is important and it helps
um it helps the what was the the sort
of the sir two ones yeah um and that uh
so how do we
produce them you talked about exercise
you talked about food
right why would we stop producing them
if we let's say
you know i eat healthier now than i ever
have
yeah so you know seemingly
doing better job with the quality of my
food the sourcing of my food
the amounts whatever it is like i'm
working out more say i'm doing a better
job with all of it
am i now producing more nad you should
be
so what if i never stop doing that um
well
we don't know of a way to continue
making it at the same levels
it'll eventually go down a bit no matter
what you do right
right so that means we might need a
little help i'll be your demo
if you want to do a test on someone who
never do you know drops their amount of
fitness
and uh stop you know i i'll stay on a
really healthy program
if you want to use me yeah well it'll
just require a few tissue samples
you need a bit of your liver or your
muscle is that okay that's fine you know
i'm a girl i'm so used to going to the
doctor anyway
my brain whoa we gotta stop there okay
this is not an animal lecture session um
uh okay um so what a um
what about cellular reprogramming yeah
this is something that i've read about
that is um kind of scary in some way
because you're talking about creating it
and
giving being able to give someone a
cellular reprogramming
yeah this isn't stem cell
transplantation this is something very
different this is
taking all the cells in the body or in a
tissue like the eye
and reprogramming them to be young again
not to behave like they're young but
literally be young again
and uh it's a hot new field there's only
four of us in the world that do this
is this what you were talking about as
soon as you came in here about eyesight
and being able to okay
yeah fantastic right um so let's go back
to an analogy um
well let me give you a new one uh so
come back disc you remember those things
oh yes oh we could we could fit ten
songs on them they were brilliant i
remember cassettes but anyway
yeah yeah me too i don't know of course
you only look like you're 20. so i'm not
sure how old you are
maybe you don't remember cassettes uh
well i'm 50.
everyone can judge very confusing uh but
these these cds they're a good analogy
because there's two types of
um issues with a cd one is you can lose
the information
which is the the silver stuff which
doesn't happen much so that's
like our dna but the epigenome reads the
songs
on the cd or our genomes okay and
aging is like the scratches right if you
take sandpaper to a cd it's not going to
play very well
and we've been looking for things that
slow the scratches down
like nad and exercise and diet and all
that slows the scratches but it doesn't
if you've got a scratch cd uh slowing
more scratches isn't going to help you
much what you need to do is polish them
so that's epigenetic reprogramming is
getting rid of the scratches
or in the case of a piano player the
demented pianist
we we get rid of the pianist and put a
new piano piano player in there
and now the music is beautiful again so
how do we
how do we do that it's a whole bunch of
like i've
read these words and i'd like you to
explain them and how and which and why
and how do we become young again oh well
how do you how do you how do you buff it
how do you
favor the scratches well this we're
talking about really the cutting edge of
science
um five years ago there's no way
i could talk to you about this even if
we knew that legally
well there's a code of ethics in science
that you don't talk about things before
they've been fully
vetted by everybody the problem with
science
so you're saying that once you start
talking about something it is so far
down the line of being proved right
and approved that
this is this is well we used to not talk
to the public
right it was you publish something and
maybe a newspaper might call you
and they get the story wrong anyway that
was how the public saw science but now
we're in a world which is beautiful
which is
and just in the last couple of years
thanks to folks like you is you can talk
directly
to the horse's mouth but the other
well i'm the one that's the horse the uh
but the issue
the issue is that science is taking
longer and longer to publish
the work that i'm talk about to tell you
about is based on 10 years of work that
hasn't yet
been fully published it's out there it's
it's on the internet anyone can read it
all of our colleagues
have read it but because it's now
basically get in line and you have to do
another two years work after you finish
because our peers are very tough for
what what is the two year well the two
years or
at least a year for a really good
journal is so the way science
works and you probably know this is uh
you you work on something you write it
up you submit it to a journal the
journal gives it to your
fiercest critics and they anonymously
can trash you
and give you advice on what to do and
typically because they want to look
smart
they'll give you about a year's worth of
work to do even if your work is really
great doesn't matter
you always expect to have another year
of work typically
problem with that is the world's moving
too fast to wait 10 years
right for this information so now what
we do as scientists is we put it out
there
for anyone to read to criticize but
we're still locked in that
you know peer review which is which is
fine and ultimately the peer review
article will be the
the record of science okay but there's
this period now where
uh science is is is more public than
ever before
and we can talk about it in ways that
don't damage ourselves so what does that
record mean once it's like really
finalized and you've gone through that
due diligence of final
phase of whatever you have to prove to
someone else what does that matter
well so we scientists like to pretend
that
we are discovering the absolute truth
never mind that
theories of science are always replaced
and revised there's there's never a full
truth except maybe
the the laws of thermite dynamics but
even newton and
einstein have been replaced so you know
there's no there's no truth but
we we do do our best and the way we do
that is
we have to go through this hazing with
our our colleagues
anonymously once we get through that if
we make it
we get approval to publish it gets
published in a scientific journal
and now that's there forever and the
only way it can go away
is if it's discovered that you made up
this data
or you made a big mistake and then you
have to retract it
and take it off the record or offline
which is really damaging to your career
fortunately nothing like that's happened
to me but it
it happens more often than not and you
fear it because
it you know people then will doubt you
going forward if it's
fraud or typically it's not your fraud
it might be someone working for you who
was desperate
for their career but that but that's
what the record is once it's printed
it's supposed to be like the bible you
don't change it um after that
anyway so that it's a slow process okay
okay and my research
is is mostly published a lot of it is
about to be published when you say
mostly published how many um
how many how many articles have been
published how many what would you call
them you'd call them
how many uh yeah articles scientific
articles just my lab
yeah um you are me uh it would be
1 000 170 or something but
what we aim for so you're really 50 170
they each take
two years how old are you yeah
once you've finally gone through the
10-year process of figuring them out
obviously you're working on an on an
incredible amount of these things
simultaneously
um so what is it then that you you're in
this phase now where
this the the information is out there
for people to read
so what is this fantastic information
that is allowing someone to
you know let's say see again yeah uh
well so there's a group of us so it's
not just
me as a loner but still it's very new
which is exciting that
everyone can hear about this very early
the idea is that we can take genes that
normally develop
embryos that are switched off when we're
old
even when we're teenagers they're gone
um
sometimes they come on in other animals
so if you
cut off your arm and you're a salamander
you know you grow back a limb
or a jellyfish you can be immortal and
come back to life
from a little piece we know that that's
possible we've forgotten how to do that
we
humans are pretty pathetic if we get
damaged we're not growing back an eye
but the systems are there to do that we
think and there are certain genes that
control those processes
wow a fellow called
yamanaka won the nobel prize in 2012
with
um professor gordon
for realizing that this exists that you
can take
old cells skin cells for example and
make them essentially age zero take them
all the way back to zero
and we call that that's pluripotent stem
cells you've probably heard
that we can now make stem cells in the
dish they could take your skin cell
turn it into a little liver or a little
little kidney or
neurons and put them back into your
brain that was worth the nobel prize and
more
and deserved what we've done is we've
said let's take
what they've learned about going back to
zero and say we don't want to go back to
zero because we're going to have the
world's
biggest tumor in our bodies we don't
want that but what if we take it partial
partially the way back take youth
halfway not all the way
and that's tricky because if you do it
too much it's going to be problematic
and if you don't do it enough it's not
going to work
but we figured out in my lab and this is
the latest
is and we're just revising this work for
um for a big journal so we hope to
have this out in in the papers soon
if you use the right combination of
these genes it's seemingly very safe
and you take cells back to being very
young but not all the way back
and when you do that you get the
restoration of function of important
tissues like the eye
so are you putting are you adding
something in yeah
what are so this is the this is cells
well it's actually you're depositing
it's genes we we we revive the existing
cells
so let's i'll use you as an example
you're you're young and functional
but imagine that you're 90. um
you know you can't see well at night a
lot of the
um the nerves in the back of your eye
are not working
what we are doing with the mice
equivalent is
we put a virus into their eye that
carries three genes
and it just goes in there and sits there
and nothing happens
it's safe are you saying this is a test
or you're saying this is part of the
process we've done this in the mice okay
and uh this is what we hope to do in
patients in a couple of years from now
and so the virus goes in and carries
three genes that
reverse aging okay then we can turn them
on with
with you wouldn't think of a virus
reversing aging just saying
well it's a it's a domesticated virus
it's a delivery
but we eventually won't use viruses
we'll use chemicals or use appeal is
this natural or synthetic or is this lab
made
oh it's it's very lab made um it's
called an adeno
associated virus which is used currently
to treat genetic diseases so
we can actually we scientists not me um
fixed genetic diseases is this crispr
it's like that but this is gene
replacement
okay um and so there's a company for
instance called spark therapeutics where
oh yes
they are curing blindness in patients
who think
as i said when you came in i was
watching a program called unnatural
selection
and i think they were featured in it and
you know
it made me a little frustrated when they
talked about how much it was
this is the problem with this that's why
we're trying to bring the cost down it's
yeah and
and it's unfortunate when you watch a
guy say you know
huh you know it's not about the amount
that you know
of the of the product or what it takes
to make it it's
it's really about what does your
eyesight mean to you
when you're figuring out a cost that's
what was in the program i'm like
wow that this doesn't go over real well
when it's cost eight hundred thousand
dollars
yeah you know because they're taking
advantage of
something that you want so badly so
yeah well in in their defense uh it
probably cost a billion dollars to get
to that point
understood i mean i i i don't i don't
overlook the fact that there's
a decade or plus with research that goes
into intuit and time and effort from
brilliant minds like yourself and and so
many others that are in a lab working on
it and the lab itself and
yes there's costs associated with it but
um
it's still it's it's so it's
unattainable right
right the good news is though that um
these costs don't stay high
they come off pattern and other people
develop cheaper ways
um it wasn't cheap to buy an airplane or
fly on an airplane
um it's still not cheap but it's
certainly affordable to
most people um you know we all have
super computers in our pockets now that
used to right
so but but i'm with you i'm not trying
to make a lot of money out of this it's
all about trying to help people
how accessible is that is this is is
this accessible yet
well the reprogramming two years from
now we'll know if it's
working okay and it should be fairly
quick within a matter of
um a few weeks we'll know if what are
the other kinds of things that people
will be able to um have fixed or cured
other than eyesight well we only chose
the eye because uh
we're crazy um because we figured it was
the hardest thing to to treat
start there and everything else is cake
pretty much uh it we also were driven by
the fact that a very
good student who whose parents were
interested in the eye so he said
is it okay if we reprogram the eye sure
go reverse aging in the eyes so he did
that yeah
but my point is that we could have
reprogrammed any
anything we just chose the eye and it
worked but it probably will work in
other parts of the body
we've given it to the entire body of a
mouse and those mice
now over a year later are still very
healthy so liver function
all good they seem healthy does it cure
heart disease
well we'll see we don't know yet but we
do know that those cells
in the eye the back of the eye their age
goes back to being young again
and they start playing the piano turning
on the genes like they were young again
because they are young again and we
actually turn back the clock
so this is the important thing that we
now know that there's a clock in the
body that we can measure it's not the
telomeres that get shorter it's
something else
it's chemical modifications on the dna
that accumulate like crust over time
and we can read that crust and put it
into a computer and it tells us exactly
how old we are
and mice actually measuring mice and uh
within a few percent error and even
estimations of when we're going to die
but that's okay that's a shock and they
make movies about that of course and
they you know you have it written on you
like here's your due date um
your done date i should say uh that's
stuff that people
don't necessarily some might want to
know that but
will you do genetic testing on um
on embryo or on on fetuses on being able
to tell
or embryo like when you do iv like i did
ivf and had my eggs frozen so when you
do uh well then when you create the
embryo you can do
testing genetic testing on that correct
and what can you find out
uh predisposition to diseases or any
major
genetic aberrations uh you can find out
a lot you can't figure out
intelligence and that kind of stuff uh
you figure out if this if the embryo
will
turn into a baby or if it will terminate
in three months will it
you know can you tell any of that kind
of stuff you're talking about how long
will you live right
you can mostly that that's caused by
broken chromosomes
oh yeah and the older the egg the more
broken it will be mine are 33 year old
eggs um
so not so broken or kind of broken they
were frozen
when you're 33 yeah okay uh that's
probably fine
40 is is the cliff be 38 in
march so you know still no kids so
that's a good thing i did that then
it is it really is though we're working
on
nad boosting compounds for
for women we have a company is it an
injection
it would be a pill that would improve
the health of
eggs and make the ovaries younger wow uh
it worked
really well in mice we've got that uh in
the works to be published soon
how long does it take to be effective uh
we just did four weeks
wow and it worked in horses we think in
a small study
so we'll try it in uh women hopefully in
the next uh one to two years
wow so that in a couple of years there's
gonna be some major stuff happening
well yeah there's a lot that can go
wrong in that time
um but there are a lot of my colleagues
who are working on this as well so
someone's going to succeed like i
was telling you when i first uh came in
there there are dozens of companies and
i'm involved with a lot of them trying
to
push them out there are some results
that are reading out from a company that
i didn't start but some
others did and that'll be uh the first
man-made drug if it works for
for aging and it's we'll know in the
next couple of months so
the important point is i talk a lot
about mice and people like oh yeah my
schmeich who cares
and this is 20 years away it's not that
was 20 years ago we're in mice now we're
doing lots of clinical trials and it's
going to happen
yeah do you um i
i i kind of want to end up talking about
i really
want to understand
i did this i did a deal with um with a
company who
um it's called one cure and it's uh they
work with
animals but the essential basis is that
it's one cure
to cure cancer for dogs as it or animals
as it is for people
yeah and so there's so much transparency
in how
we operate overall and so then of course
then you wonder
you know what causes you're talking
about broken chromosomes being
the source of aging and the source of
disease and
and things that um that kill us or make
us deteriorate
so
is there essentially
one potential drug or medicine
for everything no
not yet not yet um
most of what we've developed as a field
are
pills that and occasionally some
injections that
work a little bit so they they will
slow down aging so i'm taking some
some molecules that are not reversed oh
i heard on joe rogan
how many things you take and uh
i started writing it down and i was like
yeah i don't know where to get that
stuff
well yeah kind of that's a cocktailless
that's a that's an expert mixer but i'd
like some maybe
well none of it's a magic bullet the
they're all uh
we'll talk but the the really important
thing to know is
just like exercise won't make you live
forever or
fasting won't make you live forever we
can we now know how to slow things down
we think um but we can't reverse it
so there's no magic bullet right now but
that's still
one magic bullet for everything there's
nothing that makes the chromosomes
and all their little workers communicate
and never lose their song no not that we
know of i feel like i'm not really
describing this in a very elegant way
but
i'm sorry i can't remember all the words
you said i'm just trying to remember the
visual of it
um but so there's not one you don't do
you believe that's ever possible
well the reprogramming is pretty
interesting
if we can reprogram the body in in its
entirety
in a safe way and remember what will be
the treatment then
for the program what is it right now
right now it is a virus that you give
that delivers three genes so it's like
an iv
right or in the eye wherever you want to
put it okay it spreads throughout the
body
and then when you take it uh an
antibiotic
the antibiotic we've engineered uh well
you interve
in engineered the genes to be turned on
by the antibody so it's
not important that it's an antibiotic
but we needed a chemical that you could
give to the animal or the
patient turn on the system the three
genes
and then you don't want them always on
you just want to fix the eye
or the body and then turn it off again
so you stop the doxycycline which is the
antibiotic we use
um so it's got an on off switch which is
nice right it's
it's gonna hopefully be safer for that
reason but
imagine a world where when we're young
let's say we're in our
20s early 30s we go in and we get our
our viral treatment and so that spreads
throughout our body
and it just sits there until we need it
so when might you need reprogramming
would that be like a vaccination then it
yeah is it not is that
it'll be like a vaccination similar uh
one or two injections that's it
it's what we do in your life once in
your life and it's there
now you're genetically modified by the
way
but we're always being genetically
modified right like you said hold your
breath
you're being genetically modified it's
dramatically modified epigenetically
modified
yeah you're talking about genetically
modified putting in
extra genes three extra genes well we've
already got those genes but they're not
turned on by an antibiotic they turn on
when we're very young
but we've we've made a virus that will
deliver those genes so that we can turn
them on when we want
which is when you get hurt when you
break your spine when you damage your
eye
or potentially when you get old so then
you imagine this is futuristic but it's
not beyond science
that you you have this virus now and
if you break a bone or you break your
back or
rip your eye you get an iv of this
antibiotic
and you rejuvenate like a salamander
or you reach 60 or whatever you want and
you go
to your doctor and say just had my
epigenetic clock measured doc
and i'm biologically 75 that sucks
give me some doxycycline screw for
doxycycline you go to your pharmacy
take it for three weeks and you notice
that you literally get younger
and you wouldn't just feel younger if it
works you would look younger too
what are the what's the downside there's
got to be something that could go wrong
here yeah there's plenty of things that
can go wrong
um the worst that could go wrong is if
it goes too far and you get uh
stem cells and you they turn into a
tumor that would be
a nightmare scenario so we have to do a
lot of work over the next two years
making sure this is safe for humans
it's one of the reasons for going into
the eye because it's contained and it's
not going to spread
we haven't seen any evidence of any
toxicity in these mice that have been
given a high dose for a year now
and turned on and they're quite happy
but that's the nightmare scenario that
we do more harm than good
but for vision you know i think it's
it's a good bet that it's gonna be fine
in the eye is there any um
does this have any effect i mean if
you're giving a virus
essentially you're you're you're getting
an
injection for a virus that's going to
live in your body
um and i feel like one of the things
that i've been
you know paying attention to a lot is
gut health and
how much conversation there is around
gut health and then you think oh you put
a virus in there
now you're talking about an antibiotic
correct is that i mean that's what
doxycycline
doxycycline is a is a form of it and
there's so much
around that being so deteriorating for
gut health and
the you know your the healthy flora and
bacteria the microbiome of your of your
gut the
um healthy bacteria so
do you buy i mean are you do buy into
the gut health being really important
and does anything that you're talking
about affect that
uh definitely buy into the gut health
there's no question it's a huge field
now and it's growing that
maintaining that gut barrier
is essential and we think part of the
problem of getting old is you lose that
and you get inflammation and things leak
into your body from your gut leaky gut
leaky gut exactly so i'm i'm definitely
on that page
but these viruses um you're going to
give them in your bloodstream and
they're not going to affect
your microbiome we think um
but the positive thing about this is
that we're talking about basically
the the wright brothers have made a
glider
and it doesn't mean we're going to be
all riding in gliders lying on our
stomachs for the next hundred years
it but it does mean we can fly and we'll
make improvements
eventually it won't be a virus it could
just be a pill could be a cream
something like that
the mere fact that there's a backup copy
of youthfulness is the most important
part of this discovery whether or not we
have that
are you still questioning that i'm not
questioning it you believe that we have
that is in our gene in our genetics yeah
i mean if you believe our data
and i do uh obviously otherwise i
wouldn't try to publish it
that we can make cells young again and
turn back that clock
the clock that we can measure there's
going to be so many plastic surgeons
that are
so angry at you the vanity is out the
window
yeah and there's also going to be drug
companies they're going to be so mad at
you
because you're going to keep people
young and keep
keep the epigenetics playing the song
that we were meant to have from a young
age that keeps us looking and feeling
our best and we're not going to have
diseases
is this the that's a world right i mean
we will still get sick
but those we should want that which of
course we do of course we do and
pharmaceutical companies are smart
enough
that if they see something's going to be
a big win
they'll get on it too and sure already
they're talking i was going to say so
what has happened then
right so they're talking to you about it
yeah
well and not just me there's a whole
growing field on this
now don't get me wrong um
this is a new field and not every
scientist would agree with me
we're going to have to do the usual
fight and see
let the data win let the data speak for
itself that's fine as scientists we have
to
come up with theories and then we try to
kill them and if we can't kill them then
they might actually be right
so we're at that point but i've been
doing this for a while now i'm 50
and i haven't published anything that
they got me have you um
injected or ingested anything
uh any of your own products i have not
injected myself with virus
it's theoretically feasible but i'm not
gonna do that would you
well here's a good question if i was
95 i wouldn't have much to lose would i
right but i'm still i still have
hopefully another 30 40 years to go so
i'm not
i always do these calculations risk
reward and the older i get the more risk
i'm
tolerating yeah makes more sense but
gene therapy is very different than
taking
a little natural molecule some of them
that i take a natural
so that that's fairly safe but gene
therapy
i don't know i would probably have to
see some
a lot more safety studies before i would
embark on that
you probably would have some 90 plus
year olds that would sign up for that
shot every day every day i get people in
are you allowed to
do it no i wouldn't no there's no way
it's illegal but
um what if it was yours what if it was
are your parents still alive
my father is yeah what if your dad
wanted it yeah that's interesting oh you
get into these ethical dilemmas
if he was dying um it's
it's still unethical and i don't even
think it's legal to pull out something
from the lab and give it
to someone no but nobody needs to know
yeah well we're talking
yeah theoretically would you give it to
your dad if he was
in a position to really need it well
i don't know about that it could do some
harm anyway but if he was only had a day
to go
nothing but what's the harm then it's
true it could do some harm what's the
harm well
let me ask you would you do it oh
absolutely if
i thought i was i mean right now today
no because i would try and do every
other therapy i could
that would take care of myself in the
best way i still feel good
if i was at a point where i felt
absolutely horrible if there were things
that were threatening my quality of life
to such a degree that
it either way wouldn't you know what do
i have to lose kind of a thing
then yeah i mean you would of course
want to hang on you would of course want
to do whatever you could
and um and be able to live longer now
you know the question of would i want to
live till
200 right if you're saying aging doesn't
matter
let's just throw out a giant number and
let's just say 200.
yeah i don't know
right like i'm not sure
what's the point of life like what
what's the point of life to you
um making things better
being productive being useful that's
what gives life meaning
most people so say you've mastered the
game of aging and we
just live forever yeah then what well
then you work on another problem to make
things better
we're never going to perfect everything
in the world we've got to figure out how
to get off this planet as well
lots more to do would you live your life
any different if you were how would you
live your life different
if you were going to live until you were
200 um
i don't think i'd change a thing i'd
probably drive a little slower and
more carefully i wouldn't don't you
wouldn't yeah you're a better driver
than me
but uh we have to be careful there's
shots for that you know i'm a salamander
just grow the arm back it's gonna be
fine right
it's an interesting thought experience
if you lived for a thousand years you
probably wouldn't cross the road without
help
it's too dangerous what do you mean
well if it's a huge loss to die at 100
if you're gonna live to a thousand
and there are a lot of risks that we
take um
crossing the road is pretty dangerous
not wearing seatbelts very dangerous
and we take these risks but no one wants
to die when they're
100 if they've got another 900 years to
go we don't
let kids now ride in cars without seat
belts because it's a huge loss if they
die
and uh and so that that's the
calculation that you take fewer
risks the longer you live so are you
really not living then
i think that's a good point so i come
from australia
and what i love about the us compared to
australia
they're both great countries so yeah
i've been to australia too it's
beautiful yeah
but what's different about australia is
that the government doesn't tolerate
any major risk so
total ban on fireworks and speed cameras
essentially on every other corner
and it takes the fun out of life even if
life is longer i think of australians
and i i feel like a lot of them i know
are kind of crazy so you're surprising
me right now
yeah it's uh it's amazing you're crazy
you're trying to keep people live
forever
uh not forever no but what i'm trying to
do
i want to say this is a good point to
say that i'm not trying to make people
live longer
in an old way i'm trying to push people
out
for as long as i can in a healthy way
and then have them die very quickly
and that's what happens in the lab
that's what happens naturally if you
live over a hundred you die relatively
quickly and cheaply
the cost medical cost to keep a hundred
year old alive when they get sick is
one-third of people who die
before 100. so if we can get people out
further it's going to be
a lot of cost saving because first of
all they'll be productive for more
of their life then they won't cost as
much when they get sick
what does dying quickly look like oh
heart failure kidney failure
the the mice in our lab the really long
ones they're just overnight
like that pretty much they die well so
there's no so the deterioration that we
think there is is really something more
superficial in quality of life as
opposed to
something like liver failure just
happens yeah i mean a horrible slow
death is what happens
if you don't worry about aging because
what we do is we've we've kept the heart
quite healthy with all of the drugs that
we've got but we didn't
address the mind we were not successful
so now we've got
a couple of generations of people who
live longer but then
they lose their their identity
and that's that's a nightmare situation
so what i'm working on is keeping the
entire body
healthy and if i can't do that it's not
worth working on
well let's talk about some ways that we
can we can all really do it now
right like something that we can we've
been touching we've been talking a
little bit about like diet and exercise
and but let's let's be a little more
specific so that
um you know we can have the same answer
that i had would you take the drug now
no i wouldn't i would do everything i
could
to try and take care of myself right now
in the most natural way possible so
um you know first off would be diet you
know what's the best diet that we could
we could carry right well there's not a
one size fits all
and that's it's not a cop out
what i've done over the last 15 years is
make sure
that what i do with my diet and with
what i take
works for me and so i've been quite
scientific about it
not everyone can do that but through
blood tests through i'm actually wearing
a
glucose monitor on my arm under here a
little patch do you always wear one
now i do just for last month but i love
it it's actually now
i'm not just shoving food down in my
mouth and forgetting about it
it actually shows up on my phone and i
love that feedback
interesting i've heard two um i talked
to a another girl who does
you know tailoring of diet to keep your
blood sugar levels
you know more balanced so that you don't
get those hunger spikes and cravings and
you know she actually suggested getting
getting a little pin prick so you can
check your glucose after you eat certain
foods so that you can
so that's obviously way way better so
do is it are you actually is there
something in your skin yeah then to
yeah yeah so it's sort of is that what a
diabetic wears yes
yeah this is the latest it's a bluetooth
device you put it in once every two
weeks and it stays there you shower with
it
i was in the sauna with it this morning
it's really great um
you feel a little bit more like a cyborg
when you start
but you get used to it and then now i
wouldn't consider living without it
because it's
it's like driving without a dashboard
well i watched a program it was a ted
talk and of course i was caught by the
title which was what is the perfect diet
and i'm like i wanna know
i'll tell you what i do uh so i i don't
fall into the carnivore
camp so uh joe rogan and others are a
bit upset with me
but i i look at places in the world that
tend to live long
yeah and they have a certain type of
diet usually they don't eat a lot they
have periods of fasting either religious
or just
that's how they live um they're very
active
mentally and physically their whole
lives and they have community
so all those things we kind of know that
but i i add another level of science and
rigor
to what i do as best i can um
so what i do is first of all if there's
one thing i could say that i think works
the best
um and works for me the best is to eat
less often
that's one thing that you can do
[Music]
it's hard i know because we've grown up
with the idea that three meals a day
is the right thing and i don't think
that i'm at five
i'm at four main meals and a snack okay
that's how i go about it oh boy well
you're
not eating a lot that's for sure
probably it's better to keep
does that make a difference i'm looking
for an excuse here um this is definitely
saying no it's okay
there's definitely a difference even in
longevity uh but um
i don't know about the period of fasting
that makes a difference unfortunately it
seems to work
on both sexes by work i mean
if you fast an animal it will live
longer
sorry about that so you eat you don't
eat a lot of meat
don't eat a lot of meat and i focus on
yeah what kind of as much plant
material as i can okay do you have a lot
of beans uh no
grains not as much as you might think so
lots of vegetables
do you eat fruit then if you're just
taking it
you're checking your glucose you're
probably not biting down on a piano
on a banana or some pineapple right i'm
not and grapes and all that
so i've um low sugar so it's it's leafy
vegetables
um it is going to sound very boring no i
you're fine it's
do you want to live forever or not and
by forever i mean a long time
and really healthy right well i don't
want to live forever in fact i'm not
even i don't care about dying as you
heard from my driving record but um i've
now become a role model so i'm trying to
do my best
and learn what works so the the
vegetables
i try not to eat a lot of sugar um in my
food supply so
fruit's okay of course but a lot of
orange juice i wouldn't touch
and the so the leafy vegetables are good
the carrots are good
my wife cooks uh mostly um
she loves to cook and she's gone
vegetarian at home which has been great
um mostly because our children insisted
really based on principles yeah we've
got militant kids that's wonderful i
mean
i have such compassion if i i don't eat
the only kind of animal protein i
eat now is really fish and um
i i'm i'm guessing that there might be a
day where i probably phase that out to
too um but it's really has to do with
ethics i mean i just
it's just a horrible system yeah yeah me
too i got into a debate recently with
somebody that
you can raise animals ethically and it's
it's better for the environment and
i'm gonna look at it but i i'm with you
i think um i don't
need to worry about hurting animals
mammals i used to say i don't eat
mammals
furry things but they do taste good yeah
it's not the problem with the taste it's
just i just feel bad for the process
and you know i always say i mean you
know in fact joe
i mean he's a hunter and i know that he
is passionate i mean he eats meat but if
we all had to actually go hunt our own
meat and get it ourselves and we
didn't have didn't there was no factory
farming
the landscape of eating meat would look
a lot different and
the the emotion behind it and
and how they're treated um you know if
somebody
if i was walking down the street and you
know all of a sudden one second it was
over
that goes pretty quick and i do i have
heard that there are some farms that
that's how they raise their animals and
it is done
in a much more um
abrupt way that is not um that doesn't
create
anxiety and and um fear for the animal
but look death is death and so i'm with
you
it's a it's a it's a moral thing yeah
well and and health wise i i i tend to
put on a lot of weight i've got
bad hungarian genes and um
change them i would be yeah just a job
you need a shot for that
i mean that would sell like hot cakes oh
yeah so what we do
what i find with plant-based diets is i
don't
eat as much calorie many calories
so that that helps with my weight as
well and so i'm not as hungry either all
the time
so that's good um i'm not crazy i i i
mean i'm not
so particular i'll eat fish that's fine
i'm not
so strict i'm not the kind of person
that says you can only eat one thing and
it's my way or the highway yeah but i
think maintaining healthy weight is good
focus on vegetables focus on colored
vegetables because
when your food is stressed we believe
that the chemicals they make
turn on our own defenses so those sort
of that we discovered
linked to aging we found that many of
those chemicals that plants make when
they're under adversity
or stress they come on they make them
and then when we eat them we get those
signals
and it makes sense that we get those
cues about our
adverse environment from the plant suite
i mean i'm gonna have to jump to my
favorite part look it's like written
here and i'm like totally gonna get to
it at the end but you just said it
because i'm a winemaker
so reserve a troll yes am i saying it
right
where is virtual resveratrol if i say it
faster it sounds like what he said
um is in wine oh yeah and
one of the practices with wine with with
making wine especially high quality wine
is you drop fruit and you stress the
vine
you stress the vine so you stress the
cluster to try and grab as much water as
it can to
it concentrates the the flavor and
thickens the skin
and you want to give it you also you and
and also you don't give it too much
water you want the
you want the roots to to struggle and
strain and find
water so it's all about the struggle to
create the great wine
so oh my gosh interesting that's what
you're doing uh you're creating a very
healthy
product by doing that we need to do the
same to our bodies
drink more wine yes make our roots
pineapple oh my gosh
i was so excited when you when i was
reading about
the benefits of that and you take this
you take that supplement every day is
that right
right yeah yeah i'm not going to say it
because i said it wrong
yeah now we
we first discovered it uh 2003 we first
published that
and uh with colleagues of course and uh
we've been figuring out how it works for
the last
15 20 years um well at least 15.
and it's been up and down we first came
out and said it activates these sirtuins
that we work on
and we built a company we made a drug
here in new york it worked
quite well in psoriasis the skin
condition in
what's called a phase two study uh and
then
uh so the company was bought by one
large multinational company
uh number two in the world and then the
number one in the world
um for whatever reason you can speculate
i'm not going to say publicly
i tried to invalidate our science and
said it's all wrong
and i got sandwiched between the two
biggest pharma companies in the world
with debate about my science now that's
10 years ago when we've
we've proven that we were right and
we've got more interesting data to come
out that'll
so are you in that last two year phase
where somebody can now come in and
make you prove other things to be true
or not true
and then it'll be available no it's
available published it in science
magazine in 2013 so it's a long time ago
it's all vetted
so this isn't speculation this is a done
deal but
um when it comes to public perception
people are all confused because the
media
said oh it's the greatest thing 60
minutes and then oh it's all wrong
and then and then then it's just a mess
and no one knows about media
but this what's great about new media is
that you can talk
straight to the scientist it doesn't it
doesn't have to be a flash in the pan
headline
so anyway resveratrol works the way we
said which is activating the sort one
enzyme the way we know that actually is
we can change the enzyme
so that it still works but it doesn't
get activated by that
chemical oh wow we have a mouse that
cannot be activated
when we give it resveratrol it doesn't
live longer
so that's the proof that it works the
way we said
so uh how much do you take of that a day
what is the grams a gram how much is in
a bottle of wine a milligram in a glass
a milligram and a glass so there's about
four or five milligrams in a bottle
so please don't try to have that much
it'll
kill your liver how many milligrams does
it take to get a gram
a thousand oh god so i'm gonna have to
drink every day
be really consistent but you take a gram
a day yeah and i'm still alive i'm gonna
micro dose
that might work or is it gram micro
dosing
no a gram is a lot um but it seems to
work fine
uh in terms of overall health how
different what does it make you feel do
you feel any different
no i don't but i measure
myself with blood tests yeah um there's
a local company
and uh i can see if something is causing
trouble i'm looking at enough things
that if something
that i take causes you know i can figure
out in a day if it affects my blood
sugar
but other things take a few months to
figure out and resveratrol has been
fine and i've had my heart checked out
and it's very
healthy yes heart healthy yes of course
so is that available
uh people sell it i don't sell anything
but other people sell it
does one of your companies sell it i
don't sell anything but my name is all
over the internet with people pretending
that i sell things
i spend a lot of money on seasoned
assist letters there's more going out
soon
fun yeah that's a fun side of your job
it's unfortunate
um all right well fitness um
what kind of exercise i i am
very curious about this my my my own
fitness goes through many many
iterations
yeah uh so there's a lot known actually
and that if you were to summarize it
it's that
any movement is good walk run if you can
bike run even further if you can um
that's the overall thing but the good
news just in the last few years is
people have figured out that you don't
need to be a marathon runner or a
cyclist in a triathlon to be able to
have a benefit and again about this
stress
uh get your body out of complacency the
the high impact um intensity training
seems to be the best
get out of breath for 10 minutes or 20
minutes a day if you can or every other
day
you don't need to just be running for
marathons just
lose your breath and you you know you're
running enough or
or cycling enough when you can't carry
out a conversation easily right
right what you're doing then is telling
your body turn on your longevity genes
and protect the body and they stay on
for a number of days afterwards
really yeah how many days a week do you
recommend that
that kind of exercise the intensity it's
an it's more intense
yeah well what i'd do if i had more time
and i wasn't on airplanes all the time i
would do it
probably every other day or every third
day let my body recover a bit
is the recovery just as important
as the activity uh
it seems to be and it also matches with
periodic fasting you don't want to
always be hungry
you don't always want to be fed you want
to be fed hungry fit hungry it's that
so back to food for just a second though
with the with the fasting just to pair
up with the kind of diet with fasting um
how often so periodic fasting there's a
whole bunch
um you can do what do i do for a period
which is i
i don't need breakfast i'm not hungry
i've seen my blood sugar go way up in
the morning that's natural what happens
to me
from not eating not eating lots of blood
sugar it comes from my liver it's okay
making it that's what a lot of people
feel if you're not hungry
at breakfast i would say don't bother
eating it okay i try to skip lunch if i
can i'm not
always able to because i'm stressed out
and i'm a stress eater
but i try to skip lunch um and then i'll
eat a normal dinner
um but not too much you know i don't go
crazy on five hamburgers or whatever
and uh i also one of my tricks is i
bought some really tight shirts
so that and all of them are tight so if
i gain just a few pounds
welcome to the world of women yes it
sucks
i don't know why we complain about our
weight because you see these jeans yeah
i
know when i've gained two pounds yeah
but it's true i i do think that's true
with women versus men you know you're
you know they call them boyfriend jeans
for a reason because they fit like a guy
and so they're they're loose and you
don't know when you've gained five
pounds right until
it's too late and you've gained 15. um
so that's the fact that that's fantastic
advice
a belt probably also helps well you
don't want to change holes in your belt
that's
right exactly it's a great indicator the
belt okay and so periodic fasting has
helped me keep my weight down okay uh
combined with exercise
you do this every day so the pure your
fasting goes every day
right it's a struggle is it a 16 8 split
yeah so i try to do at least 16 up to 18
hours
do you do the twenty four twenty and
four i can't go for a whole day without
eating
well it's 20 hours off four hours on uh
that might be
what i do yeah on a good day um
i can't do the three day thing so oh
three days of fasting yeah that's real
deep cleanse
um and and by that i mean at the
cellular level there are
there's this process autophagy have you
heard of this so autophagy is
the word that means your cells are
eating themselves and what they do is
they they recycle protein
as energy source and that doesn't happen
really deeply until after day three of
not eating
so this is this is to improve your
health
yeah so if you have huh
well it could be for religious reasons
but i think you'd only want to do it
for health yeah it's not it's not fun no
not at all but what if you had serious
issues and disease you know
disease or um you know things wrong
with you it helps you on a cellular
level right
it does and it's thought that it can
delay or prevent um
the accumulation of misfolded proteins
that cause many diseases alzheimer's
being won
but yeah if anyone has an illness you
know i'm not
a practicing physician i'm not i'm a phd
so i can talk about the signs all day
but
if you're if you're sick please do talk
to your doctor what
is interesting though is some diseases
respond really well to
fasting um cancer being one of them
not all cancers but is it true that
cancer feeds on sugar
it does does it feed on protein uh
depends on the cancer but most of them
like to carry out what's called
aerobic glycolysis which is basically
plenty of oxygen in the body but they
act as though there's not enough oxygen
and they use
sugar directly for energy and instead of
taking it through the mitochondria
long story short cancer cells get
addicted to the blood sugar to the
sugar in the body and by starving them
of that it seems to
force them to kill themselves so it can
be beneficial and there are drugs
like a diabetes drug called metformin
that is also
sometimes given to cancer patients to
simulate fasting
and that seems to help too i would be in
favor of something to simulate fasting
what about uh supplements then
well that that's what my work's been on
it's how to
understand why does fasting and exercise
work
and i think we have a really good idea
of these genes um and then what
molecules can you take
to right and what can we get like i i
know that like
there are probably some things that
you're able to get a hold of that
might be more difficult for us
uh no yeah no well then tell me i'm a
regular citizen
i'm not um doing anything subversive
mm-hmm
so there is i mean i don't think you're
doing anything wrong but you do have
availability some
well you have a lab you have seven years
i also
fortunate that we've carried out
clinical trials and um yeah we have some
material
yeah yeah in my basement so i actually
go down and i just yeah yeah
yeah sure we all do so what would you
recommend then
for well i don't know who can don't have
a basement of
um yeah medicine
well yeah i'm a professor at harvard
medical school and i get into trouble
when i say this is what people should do
so don't what disclaimer so is it better
so what do you do
what i do uh so i
when i don't have my own basement supply
um i go
to what everyone else would do is either
go to the
the vitamin shop or to
amazon or an online shop
and look for the following look for a
reputable company
how do you know it's really hard are
there there are larger companies that
have been around for a while
i won't name names but you know if this
is a company that just
popped up in florida or utah stay away
until proven otherwise they need to show
a certificate of purity
ask for that and there's a thing called
gmp which is good manufacturing
practices
and uh so look for gmp in the u.s other
countries have different
measures but that means they're pure and
so
let's take resveratrol for example i
wouldn't ever take the 50
stuff because you don't know what's in
the other 50
and actually it can have a um
a diarrhea effect so someone might not
mind that
oh yes okay well i i don't want diaries
i don't eat that no some people might
that is true
but not on a plant-based diet tends to
help all work fine
yeah that's another reason but the uh
now you've distracted me so the
resveratrol is uh
don't take the 50 yeah here's something
that's that's important
uh so always go for high quality i do
anyway
resveratrol has has been looked at by
thousands of
people in labs it's been studied a lot
and sometimes things work and sometimes
they don't that's science right
clinical trials sometimes they work
sometimes they don't
more recently people have gotten
clever and realized that resveratrol is
a very insoluble molecule
it's chemists would call it brick dust
okay right so if you eat brick dust it's
not going to get absorbed
same with resveratrol so what do you
need well you need to put it in
something
that it dissolves in okay it's not water
it's something like olive oil what i
what i do is i make a special type of
yogurt which is good for my
supposedly good for my immune system and
i just mix that with a couple of spoons
and i take that in the morning and if
anyone's gonna get angry that that's
breaking my fast
and that's breakfast two spoonfuls of
yogurt okay
i don't think that that's a problem but
those spoonfuls those bacteria are very
healthy bacteria i make it myself
oh do you ferment your own i do wow
from special bacteria i mean i shouldn't
say wow you're a scientist
but well it's not that hard i just milk
in a jar add the bacteria and
some other feeding stuff shake it put it
in it in the defrost setting on my oven
for
overnight and i'm done and is it ready
in the morning yeah it's easy oh wow
i don't sterilize anything by milk do
you mean real dairy milk or
are you talking about like almond milk i
don't know if it would work with almond
milk really try
but i use whole milk so you don't have
to have a problem with dairy
i don't know but those who do this is an
issue to figure out
i'll stick with my coconut yogurt uh
okay but but anyway back to resveratrol
that's right that's what we do
with the reservation uh i spoon it in
mix it and i eat that but the clinical
trials where people have
given it with food it's shown promise
lowering a blood sugar lowering your
cholesterol
okay and again that the public
doesn't have the time or probably uh
the interest in reading all of these
papers that i do but let me
you know tell you that that there's a
lot of studies where in humans it's
beneficial okay
and uh so i'm i'm still taking it okay
uh i was once asked by a reporter of the
new york times
um isn't it a conflict of interest to be
studying these molecules in
mice and people and taking it at the
same time
and uh i thought about it and i said uh
i want to be the first person to know if
there's something toxic
don't i yeah i think that's that's what
i'm saying have you taken any of your
own have you
would you take the shot because that's
the ultimate right testament to the
product is that
you take it the the day i stopped taking
something you want to know because
i've seen something why i want to know
what you take yeah
well all right well you're smarter than
the average bear
i don't know about that but um uh
we won't but uh so
reserve a troll or why am i saying that
wrong please say it for me one more time
uh resveratrol resveratrol so
resveratrol and then what else do you
take uh
i take something called nmn which is a
molecule that the body turns into nad
nad is we talked about earlier boosts
the circuit activity we
don't know if it has an effect on human
aging but in mice it looks really good
okay so is that available to people can
they get that yeah it's out there
it's out there so i'm going to tell you
something that
i just recently decided to explore
so every day i wake up to
hundreds of emails where do i buy this
stuff
can you sell it to me i can't do that
i'm a scientist
and i'm objective i need to be able to
be trusted
um the moment i start selling something
then i'm gonna you know you're gonna say
well he just says that because he sells
it
that's true but then with with this
dilemma that i'm saying
here's what i do here's what the sign
says you're on your own that's not fair
either is it
i i struggle with that what i tell
hundreds of people every day
other than tough luck i don't want to do
that so what i'm working with
another professor at harvard is the
possibility of
giving at least a third party
the means to test products and they can
have a seal of approval if it's at least
what they say it is
doesn't mean it'll work but at least
it's not grasping a vetting process so
that there can be a
third party that you trust that is
approving disapproving
and being able to identify the quality
of these ingredients
right that's great so then i'll i'm
doing what i can to help everybody so
that those are the two
main things nmn which you can buy and uh
resveratrol the third thing is an
interesting one that really worked for
me
um so i don't take things really nearly
right i don't just take five things and
hope that they work i'm
testing rigorously take it stop take it
stop measure
right so it's very scientific even
though it's a small clinical trial of my
dad and myself and my wife
which you know a lot of doctors would
say is not not good science
and i'm not going to publish it but
i have learned that there's one drug
talk about it i can talk about it
i think it's useful information for
people the third one is metformin this
is the diabetes drug
that is used in millions of people
around the world
and it's given to people who have a
certain amount of blood sugar that
we call diabetes type 2 diabetes it's
the first drug you get
and it's as drugs go very very safe
the worst thing that tends to happen to
maybe a third of people is you get
an upset stomach feeling which you can
mitigate
uh usually but what doctors don't
usually do is give a medicine before the
disease happens
it's pretty rare right and uh but more
and more evidence has accumulated both
in animals
and in human studies of hundreds of
thousands of people
that show that people who take metformin
are relatively less susceptible to
other diseases besides diabetes cancer
heart disease frailty uh alzheimer's
and when i look at that data i say that
sure looks like a longevity molecule to
me and it's in that
pharmacy right across the street so it's
pretty tempting right and so what what
i did was i started taking it a couple
of years ago my father was already
taking it because he
passed the threshold of diabetes um
and it's been great in terms of how i
feel
yeah how my my body is reacting and you
know hopefully
it's uh it's doing some good it says
something if you feel different because
it is hard sometimes to know if
something actually has
is making you feel and you're like gosh
i hope it's it's like
me getting facials when i was 20 i'm
like you know i don't know i kind of
look the same but i'm hoping in 10 or 20
years it really pays off and then
finally in 10 or 20 years but
you know it's really nice to um have
that
more instant gratification and
confirmation that you're on the right
track with things it's a long-term
investment for sure and i'm very glad
that i started doing this
yeah in my 20s and 30s interesting
hopefully now paying off
um i haven't got any gray hair well i do
so you can find something to reverse
that you'd also put hairdressers out of
business so
um you're in the business of shutting
people down
um but no this is i mean at the end of
the day this is
there will always be science is always
uh going you know
there's always going to be advancements
and learning and it doesn't mean that
there
are uh it's putting people out of
business they're just going to have to
find new and for all the new that you
find out
they will find new to accompany it so
it's an evolution
it's not a problem you just if you're
afraid to evolve then it is a problem
right right it the the this
an analogy is uh people used to say well
if you if you make everyone wear seat
belts what what's going to happen to the
body shop repair
people well who they'll figure out other
things to do of course
but we need to save lives so same here
if we can
slow down aging and prevent or push off
most of the diseases that cause our
healthcare system to be overly burdened
and will continue to get worse
then people will find other things too
and though you know we're not saying
that
we're going to cure cancer tomorrow as
much as we're going to be able to cure
aging
but i do hope that with these molecules
and ones that we're developing
through the fda and can be prescribed
that people will live till until their
90s and be able to play tennis and yeah
hang out
great grandkids um one the one last part
of um what we can do is sort of
the modalities the out outside of
fitness and outside of food what we can
do
um and you were talking about being in
the sauna
but is ice part of that too
it is um so i was skeptical when i
started writing my book
the publisher said oh you got to put
this other stuff
it's all the rage you know they said
cryo is so hot right now
said oh come on that's that's pseudo um
then i went with uh with joe rogan to a
cryo center and i felt great
um probably because i was still alive
because it was so so awkward temperature
of surface of mars for goodness sakes um
but uh i looked into it and so it's not
a bunch of hui uh there is some good
science
not just looking at people's physiology
but you can look at
lots of people who have been doing this
particularly saunas there's a lot of
research on that in
the nordic countries that mostly they're
men for some reason but mostly men who
do this are protected from heart disease
or at least associated with protection
and you can go the other way you can
look at what happens at the molecular
level which is what i do
and at the molecular level uh stressing
cells either by a bit of temperature or
a bit of cold does fit with the theory
that you are boosting longevity genes
there's one called sort of number three
there are seven in our bodies number
three
responds to cold and it helps make brown
fat in our bodies and brown fats thought
to be very very helpful
and metabolically make brown fat well
you turn your white fat into
beige or brown fat and then what then
what happens with the brown what's that
what's
a brown do well it does two main things
so it's full of mitochondria
burning energy so your metabolism ramps
up you can eat more without getting fat
which is good
for us the other thing it thinks we
think it does is it secret
they secrete put out these little
proteins that make us healthier
we don't know what they all are but
there's some evidence that
they make the rest of the body healthy
as well you can take brown fat and put
it into animals and
it seems to be helpful is there any
other colors white and brown is that it
that uh and beige and beige so this
makes brown fat
it toward pushes it towards brown but
the older you get the harder it is to
make brown fat
so you want to start when you're young
so i'm i'm 50 now
i'm just starting doing this cryo like
actually i do a cold plunge which is
even worse yeah i've done a few of those
myself in fact there's
some of us here we uh we know gabby rhys
and laird hamilton
yeah and they do a ton of that there and
i've done it a few times and brought my
friends along
the very last time i did it which was
probably the fifth time
i actually enjoyed it i was like ready
to get in probably because i was so
damn hot from the sauna
being at 220 plus that uh
that i was looking forward to the ice
but i really like
i probably was in there for five minutes
i was like it just felt so good to me
yeah yeah you really do get used to it
and uh
you can tell yourself it feels good um
i'm not there
fully yet my son who does this with me
he's now
up to 15 minutes in this 3-4 degree
celsius yeah yeah so he's he's uh
he's gonna have a lot of brown fat
throughout his life i'm gonna make
t-shirts
brown fat brown fat is good fat brown
fat burner what i want is what does it
what does it do
brown fat what what will be our t-shirt
uh
i'm uh i'm a brown fat builder i'm a
brown brown fat builder
bring on the brown fat bring out the
brown fat
my fat is [ __ ] your fat's so beige
mine's so brown
cute i'll let you know i'll send you one
um uh so all right well i like to wrap
up by just
asking what uh what your greatest lesson
in life has been
ah okay i haven't even thought so this
is off the cuff
the greatest lesson in life is um
don't worry it's going to be okay in the
end that
what we worry about in our daily lives
it's not worth it we live in utopia
ask someone 200 years ago what it'd be
like to live like
we do never having really to most of us
to worry about
food and shelter
now we're living in nirvana so when we
get upset
somebody tweeted this or somebody said
that about me behind my back
these are pretty minor things and so
that i've learned that
on the very bad days it's never as bad
as you think and on the very good days
it's never as good as you think
so try to be steady so i'm now 50 and i
don't go through these wild
swings of worrying and then
euphoria you know maybe i've learned to
cope with my uh
bipolar issues but that that's the truth
don't stress out too much it's going to
be okay if you find a mission in life
and stick to it it's going to be okay
like well you've been sticking to your
mission very well i should also say that
you have a book that just came out right
called lifespan yeah lifespan why we age
and why we don't have to
so thank you for that i uh i will be
picking that up so
along with all of the um supplements
and now i think we have your phone
number somewhere someone to contact you
so
if i can't find it i'll look for a
recommendation of a source
yeah i wrote down what i do in detail um
towards the end of the book okay and
then part two is what
what i do and why we think it works yeah
well thank you and congratulations on an
incredibly successful career
and uh i look forward to a couple of
years from now when
everything's published and products are
even well not products from you
but well maybe drugs we hope yeah more
is accessible to
improve quality of life everybody wants
that so right and when we both come back
10 years younger people will get
suspicious
not a problem to me thank you that's
good thanks jennica thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today
i hope you enjoyed it if you like what
you heard today and you want to hear
more
please click on the subscribe button